mettez bien non mais t'es bien les
fesses en arrière à mon avis mais
attention attention aux doigts glissent
pas eric à monaco joue pour ça qu on va
on va jouer vous allez pouvoir gagner
des places pour le cirque boorman
morineau à paris ce sera pour tous
publics 150 places je vais tourner la
roue on va jouer à fouetter c'est gagné
fouettez c'est gagné c'est très simple
une personne sera désigné par la roue
pour être le partenaire de rodolphe qui
va réaliser un numéro de fueter qui
c'est là qu'ils sont déjà fait fouetter
vous aimez tous les fous et isabelle ça
dépend si c'est moi qui le tient ou si
c'est moi qui reçoit merci
[Applaudissements]
on va mettre un objet dans la bouche
d'eric à un objet l'on va démarrer par
quoi alors on va démarrer alors ça c'est
assez
c'est ça c'est le journal ça tout
simplement d'accord une journal qui a
été donc voilà rouler mois qu'il met à
d'accord que ce privilège
d'accord mais chapeau pour la radio
merci rodolphe halle aux grains
également ont franchement au remake
teulé le bien dans les décalages comment
ça va mais attention derrière et cannes
ayez pas peur rodolphe et ça toute la
journée
il en a fauté de la grossesse à cyril
arrêter de faire rigoler c'est vrai par
contre bougeait pas à bouger mais tu es
bien non mais t'es bien les fesses en
arrière à mon avis attention attention
rondo a pris ce pari car on a forgé pour
sac
[Musique]
attention
on va jouer maintenant on va jouer
maintenant avec un truc un peu plus
court voilà là on se rapproche de
thierry moreau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
odense excellent
ah ben laden audrey elle va passer
encore plus facile pour inviter tous les
publics au cirque
ayem est et l'autre en effet le pas
c'est plus est plus petit ça un peu plus
petits après le but c'est pas la mouche
et non plus n'ont gardé beaucoup de
choses avec elle en plus cela c'est pas
possible
ac je peux pas
[Applaudissements]
en place sur le site
[Musique]